[Music]
hello and welcome to pointed questions
my name is Brent Weinbach with me is
Donnie Devon Ian our guest today is
Victor who is a firefighter we will be
talking to him about fires and
friendship and this episode pointed
questions how long have you been a
firefighter for I've been with my
current department for about 11 years
and then prior to there I was actually
forced by a man for four years is what's
a harder job working in a city
environment or in the rustic rural
environment well they're definitely
there each difficult in different ways
obviously in the mountains you don't
have as much like traumatic experiences
that you see and stuff like that so you
don't see people obviously laid out hurt
all that kind of stuff and children and
all those types of things but the
physical aspect of forest firefighting
is definitely way harder especially when
you're only getting paid like 11 bucks
an hour those guys are seriously
underpaid are the fire did the fires act
differently in those environments oh
absolutely
yeah they're way different obviously a
structure fire they when they occur they
it's kind of an exponential thing so a
little room catches on fire and then
every minute it's doubling in size so
it's really based upon arriving there
very quickly
and being able to act very quickly
versus force obviously you're not going
to throw your neck out to go save a
bunch of trees you know what I mean so
it's just kind of animal skin yeah it's
just fundamentally different to the
fires have different personalities in
the two different environments uh they
do only because in a structure fire
you're obviously you're inside with the
fire in a you know in a compartment area
so they're more threatening it they're
more threatening correct do you think
that fires have personalities or 100%
what are some different kind of
personalities encounter angry angry
they're all angry they're all angry are
there any nice fires no no you know
let's maybe make hire but you're looking
at it from a distance you didn't look at
a fire sometimes and think oh this is
fun
ain't nothing you know they do you ever
think that's that fire thinks thinks
it's something that's nothing absolutely
not no every fire is a threat but even I
got candles not know I mean oK we've
been reason for yeah but when we speak
of fire is obviously I'm referring to
more things that are burning that
shouldn't be burning and that mentality
of oh yeah I got this is very dangerous
mentality because generally speaking
things go south when you're not
expecting them to so if you're not
expecting things we're waiting for them
to go south then it's kind of late at
that point you know what I mean did you
ever play with fire a lot when you're
younger all the time that's do you think
that's why you became a fire
I mean awed by our most I would say the
majority of firemen are definitely
obsessed with fire yeah Louie
yeah that's interested you ever light
anything on fire a ton of stuff did you
have to have a fireman come down and put
it out no but definitely I got spanked
and grounded many times for lighting
things on fire what did you let on fire
my house my carpet ah yeah I'm purpose I
did yeah I mean I was three four years
old well did you ever used to take apart
firecrackers and stuff and I actually
used to build them uh-huh mm-hmm so most
firemen are have they are always they're
fascinated with fire absolutely they're
they played with fire a lot when they
were kids
I would say the majority the majority
play to the fire but definitely I think
it's one of those things where when you
become a fireman
fires are your craft it's your passion
like I became a fireman to fight fire
you know the 90% of what we do is
medical and obviously helping people is
in general in any way that you can is a
big reason that most people become
firemen but the primary reason is
definitely if I fire because it's
something that you you look at a fire
and you want to conquer it you know you
want to in order to fight fire do you
need to understand how to make fire and
what I mean by that it's not just start
lighting something on fire but do you
need to understand how to make fire
happen I would say vital red not really
but part of becoming a fireman it's it's
a very long process actually most people
don't realize that the amount of
training education that we go through it
took me seven years it took 37
tests not counting the Forest Service
when I was with them but the process of
becoming a municipal fireman is
extremely extremely difficult you have
to be physically is there a certain
level of physical fitness that you have
to be at yes to be a fireman and can you
if you're not at that level you won't
make it correct yeah they won't let you
in know there's an actual physical
agility test that you have to take
before you join any department how much
you have to weigh well weight is really
not the issue you have to accomplish how
much how much you have to lift you even
that that's not there's no set number
like they say you know on the force in
the fire service you have you know fire
oxes and Firefox's so you got smaller
guys they're guys and they both serve
their different purposes know what
you're doing little guys can wiggle
around yeah cuz I call foxes well not
really but you know this is kind of like
foxes and oxes you say pretty much yeah
like smaller do you a target so you an
ox you call it or not he's not I'm
definitely a bigger dude well no I'm
because I'm wondering what the scale is
you know because if you're a fox I'm
thinking oh wow going on with an ox okay
you're like 195 made to two of co-sin uh
235 yeah you 6-2 6-3
uh-huh are you a classic fireman I'm not
really sure how to define a classic
fireman in it well you know I mean what
like is there such thing as a classic
fireman you know I'm Isaac classic guy
who you know saves the day and uh what I
would say in general people have like a
general idea of what they think a
fireman is or looks like or whatever
back you know 60 70 80 years ago 100
years ago traditionally firemen were
bigger guys because obviously there's a
lot of physical strength needed to
perform the job all your gear when you
add it all up and you're carrying your
tool I mean it's around 80 90 pounds of
gear auditioning addition to what you're
going to go do in the fire
what if foxes for like tech stuff kind
of behind the board's now now that we're
all in the same place but especially
when it comes to like you know urban
search-and-rescue going into small
confined spaces and stuff
that I mean at the end of the day it
really doesn't matter how big you are
it's can you do your job is firefighting
a masculine job I mean there is there a
sense of masculinity that comes with
being a firefighter yeah I'm sure
there's women on the on the force or are
better but is it that do you feel a
sense of masculinity as a firefighter
yeah I would say overall definitely do
you feel like more of a man and than me
then say us no no not at all there's no
there's no sense of like we're kind of
like you know more warrior types now
guys I mean anybody in civil service
whether it be the military the police or
fire it's all kind of the same deal you
know they're just different beasts that
they're battling so to speak sure do you
think there are guys up that are in your
department that do feel that way that
are feel more manly than other men but
the fire service is funny it's kind of
like it's kind of like anybody's regular
family right and your family you've got
people who act a certain way think a
certain way and then you've got other
ones that aren't on the same page so the
fire service as a whole it's it's like
if like society it's like anything else
so you there's not a particular
abundance of sort of machismo in the
fire department it's just as much as
there would be in any yeah I would say
you know the difference being that
generally speaking different fire
stations have a certain culture within
the culture like the fire service in
general has its own culture we have our
own customs we have our own traditions
and even within each department every
station has its own little culture so
typically the more aggressive guys who
you know really get after it so to speak
they tend to kind of congregate in the
busier areas of whatever city you worked
in so like the the places I've worked
tend to be you know a collection of guys
are more aggressive in general so you're
in the more usually working the more
yeah aggressive yes with the aggressive
groups
yeah um and within that that more sort
of macho I don't know
group setting is there a real strong
sense of camaraderie oh very very strong
I've been with my crew for eight years
now how many in the career we have 10 10
people we have a truck company an engine
company and a rescue which is an
ambulance and we've been in 10 years so
are you best friends yeah I mean we hang
out on the job off the job you guys
sleep in the is it a similar thing where
you guys are sleeping in this sort of
dormitory type thing at the fire station
job is that a real thing yes it's a
24-hour shift
I had a minimum but often we work you
know 48 72 years I'm sorry how long is
this shift a minimum of 24 hours minimum
of 20 how long what's a maximum shift
for our department it's 96 hours Wow so
you guys are kind of bunked up and then
are you sleeping the whole time in case
you need to do something then you spring
up and yeah so kind of the way it works
is uh I mean the daily life is every day
you come to work you get there around
6:30 in the morning you put all your
stuff check all your gear make sure
everything's fire ready and then I mean
we cook we go to the store that's why
most most supermarkets you'll find
firemen at the store or somewhere around
10 o'clock ish in the morning al hafi
because we go shot together and then you
cook two meals for the day cooking is
kind of a big deal at the station huh
what do you guys need our eggs and
Transplant you find what's on sale you
cook lunch and dinner and then breakfast
is usually kind of like everybody shows
up eats leftovers has cereal or whatever
do you guys do is there the pole is that
a thing that you guys actually slide out
is that a real thing or is interested
into a real thing our speed or what it's
for speed yeah because if there is a
fast way to get down any a two-storey
slash three-story fire station is going
to have a pole or slide why you have
stairs anyways yeah for dippers and all
the dormitories in a 2-story station or
generally upstairs you have your own
room or is it you do so there's not I've
sort of seen this depicted in I don't
know cartoons and stuff where it's you
know this is like a bunch of beds in one
room you know like kind of like a almost
military style or something yeah so all
the stations used to be that way it was
just bunks yeah big open rooms but would
gentrification on gentrification
modifications you know for females and
stuff like that yeah they're obviously
on making all the changes to all the
fire stations it's required now so
so everybody has own room there they are
they're actually building rooms as we
speak
we still have fire stations that are
being converted right now you have you
worked in settings where they were it
was bunks yes
what do you obviously probably prefer
your own room or do you like this it's
like camaraderie as well the bunks I do
the bigger problem is not really so much
when you're sleeping because when you
sleep you sleep but we still have big
locker rooms where everybody would hang
out in the morning get dressed for the
day and you know a lot a lot of like
hanging out their buddies kind of happen
in the morning chain everyone's yeah bs
and around when you were in the bunks
did you guys ever stay up late just
talking about life and talking about
girls and stuff like that absolutely I
mean yours kinda like it's not like a
sleepover town almost at a minimum again
one third of your life is spent with the
people you work with every day so I mean
we are extremely extremely close do you
guys joke around a lot all the time do
you guys mess around with equipment ever
that's it for fun for fun you mess
around with the hoses and stuff I mean
when we're training you got a train hard
play hard so yeah occasionally there
might be a water fight or something like
that but we take our job a ok sir wait
when there's a water fight like our
people can blast it super hard with
these hoses or sometimes does it hurt or
no it doesn't matter
oh really it'll knock you down I mean
obviously you're not going to take a
two-and-a-half-inch like large dam
Burhan line and just throw it on
somebody because that could be dangerous
but the smaller ones sure you know
uh-huh
has anyone ever as a joke knock somebody
down with a with the water hose oh it's
happened sure uh-huh
have you ever gotten injured by water no
no have you been injured by fire
I've got burned I've been burned I mean
most firemen it so the fire service is
interesting to you because depending on
where you work it's very different right
the see that I work for is a very busy
city there's a lot of lower-income area
which generally equates to shooting
stabbings more fires more problems in
general right so yeah I mean if you work
in that kind of environment where you
burn pretty regularly I mean you're
going to get burnt you know yours where
he's oh where have you been
like mostly around the areas that are
more exposed so generally if you go to a
fire your ears and your neck or taint or
in your hands kind of pain - you have a
cook you don't have gloves on or
something and you're fully covered but a
fire is a fire yeah a lot of times where
you reach a certain point in any fire
where you kind of have to make a
decision like okay I better nail this
thing quick or things are going to go
really badly for me you know everything
in the fire service is risk versus gain
everything that you do because there's
an inherent risk to fighting fires so
constantly if your mind the big thing
that is going is risk versus gain you
know is there ever a thought when that
you think okay I could go back in to
save this dog or whatever it is and or
then you think it's not worth it if I go
in to save the dog it's you know oh it's
huge the mentality is I always have to
save everything always so even if it's
just even if the odds are that it's it's
not going to survive or whatever the
case may be
yeah I mean that I think that in general
most people that do this job they have
that mentality like you're not gonna
you're not going to give up period right
obviously I'm not going to run into
something that is going to kill me
instantly right but again the rent
versus game thing there is no stopping
you know you're going to keep risking to
gain as far as you can go it must be a
very fulfilling experience to be the
hero right I mean to be I mean to be a
hero right and save people's well if it
is fulfilling but the hero word for
again for the firefighters is it's it's
a it's kind of like a it's weird to me
they don't like that no I think in
general most people don't they don't
like to be thought of as heroes no I
don't think so it's like anything in
life right the way I look at it is I
signed up to have this job and I'm the
fireman and I signed up to have a
certain amount of risk but understand
that it's not like we're just a bunch of
guys sitting around we get hired by city
and then we just show up at a fire
station I mean we study our craft
tremendously there's all kinds of
education and training that goes into
fighting fire
from a scientific level to a physical
level to a mental level I mean we train
forward so it's not something I don't
show up at a fire like scared you know
what I mean you show up to a fire you're
like okay this is the situation I have
this is what I have to do to accomplish
my goals have you ever been scared
planning a fire I've had a few uh I
guess [ __ ] moments in my career not
many I don't know if swearing yeah yeah
yeah totally yeah I definitely had a few
oh [ __ ] moments again if you work in a
busy place something it's impossible not
to you what was it what was one of those
moments just being real deep in a fire
where you can't find it and it's getting
really hot you're getting pushed down to
the floor I think what a lot of people
don't realize is when you go into a
building it's on fire you actually can't
see anything literally like it's put a
scarf over your eyes and that's what
you're looking at because of all the
smoke and everything I think people
there's a misconception that when you go
into a fire you're looking at the fire
and you're going to attack it but if you
ever look at like buildings are on fire
the volume of smoke that's produced you
literally have zero visibility so you're
working blind literally when you're on
your way down to a fire do they give you
a map of the apartment or the place
you're going no no but that's also part
of the whole the whole deal right so we
go on medicals ninety percent of the
time like I'd say our firehouse runs I
don't know roughly 14 15 calls average a
shift so every area every city's built
in general timeframe right so say that I
work for I already kind of have a mental
layout of the buildings and how they're
built where the kitchen should be where
the bedroom should be and all that kind
of stuff the downside to that is or the
other side to that is that a lot of
these buildings especially in lower
income areas get chopped up and like the
big Victorian homes get chopped up into
two or three units so sometimes you hit
a wall door where there shouldn't be one
but you know that's all part of the deal
working around it what percentage of
calls are actually for fires but I'd say
roughly like 10% or so Oh so most of
them are not most of them are not most
of what we do is medicals people having
heart attacks have you ever going to
call for a cat stuck in a tree that's
have actually really yeah and you had to
get go up a tree and well you can't
that's kind of interesting uh have you
guys ever seen a cat skeleton in a tree
we were called actually to get a cat
down once oh we we once saw a cat up
there's actually up on a telephone pole
or something like that but it was stuck
up there but anyway no I have not seen
this cat skeleton in a tree that's the
point if they get up they can get down
so we've actually responded to calls for
that and you know generally we're just
like open a canteen I put it at the base
of the tree and the cats going to come
down right let me tell you just tell
them that yeah but there was one time
where we actually there is a park and
there was like 20 or 30 kids around or
like I'll manage this little kidding up
there
alright let's sort of ladder and go up
there and sure enough I get up right
within arm's reach of the cat soon as I
go to grab the cat he jumps ping pongs
all the way down the branches falls flat
on his face and then runs off so it was
OK at the end of it but the kids kind of
freaked him out so uh-huh when you when
you came back down off the ladder with
the kids shaking your hand and stuff or
everything they're they're cold or
little kids are just losing their mind
in general I mean do people ever get
really okay actually are there any other
people on the for is it called is it
call to force even though it's not I
mean it's a fire department as opposed
to the police department yeah I'd say
force is usually more reference to the
police department yeah um what do you
call it like what's the what's your name
for the force what's the fire department
saying for the force I mean it's really
there's really no names just the fire
department you know there's anybody in
your department that does like to sort
of bask in the glory of being a
firefighter you know I mean you're
always going to have a show-off or two
you know you got some in your unit not
in my unit no not really my department
specifically again where our culture is
definitely a little more you know humble
in general I would say like you see some
guys we run around with their fire
t-shirts on when they run around Home
Depot just trying to show off a little
bit not just show offices they're proud
of being firemen which is fine is the
wrong with that but specifically my
department it's like a big no-no to wear
any kind of fire gear if you're not
actually working you know we can't apply
ourselves a bit of humble department
yeah
do you have rival
their rivalries between departments know
between units and snow not at all
because we're the best fire department
so yes inherently like you know there is
every fire departments got its own kind
of personality you ever showed up to a
fire in the other departments there
already yeah we work with other
departments now yeah Oh is there ever
any tension about who who's taken this
building and stuff like that no not
really I mean whoever's area it is just
kind of runs the show and you supplement
them however they need it I kind of
equate our department to like the Bad
News Bears we're kind of like you know
obviously you got a lot of training
classes even if you're hired to become
you guys are like Joker's but you get
the job done or so exactly exactly like
if you have a room full of firemen from
different departments generally speaking
our guys are in the back you know having
the most fun but when it's time to go to
work we go to work you know what if it's
some of the hijinks you guys get into is
kind of like the more the Joker get guys
yeah I mean it's just it's constant you
know when you're with your buddies it's
just stupid jokes all day long you know
I think the fire service in general like
you do see a lot of really really bad
things and the reality of it is it's
there's a lot of tough moments you know
especially when it comes to like
children who are seriously injured or we
see a lot of abused elderlies and kids
and stuff like that so the only real way
to combat that is to have fun at work
share yeah that's really the only way to
deal with it so let me show up on a free
laying you've got people there
yard sales out of their car all over the
freeway I mean it's it's you have to
have fun at work because if you don't
have these cute some pretty dark stuff I
mean yeah have you have has anyone have
used have you seen any dead bodies and
stuff because it is on a regular basis
really okay yeah yeah the area I work
has a lot of freeways next to it so a
lot of high speed crashes you know
people they just hurt themselves all the
time have you ever seen any deaths
because of the fire yeah as there has
ever been any people that you guys
weren't able to
from the fire and you but they were
alive when you got there but the organ
again back to the visibility thing you
know when something's on fire you show
up and the primary thing that you're
thinking when you're going in or I have
to put the fire out and I have to see if
there's anybody in here I mean that's
that's our main purpose right so when
you go in you're constantly looking for
people are down and they tend to be down
actually near like exits and windows or
stuff like that because people usually
will try and get out of the building
before they get overcome by smoke but
there's definitely some fires where it's
it's too late you know if you come
across somebody in that situation and
it's too late you just leave them there
you know there's nothing you can do mmm
it's just part of the gig you know have
you carried all sorts of different kinds
of people over your shoulder no we don't
nobody that hat doesn't happen we don't
carry them over our shoulder like in the
movies no I mean I never happens no now
you're going to even a kid or something
I mean maybe a kid but you have to
understand again people they just don't
understand like if you have a fire
inside of a building you literally are
your hands and knees and sometimes your
belly if it's that hot if you stand up
you will literally burn like you cannot
survive it's that hot our safety gear is
designed in a way to take a certain
amount of heat but when you're getting
up four or five hundred degrees you know
it's it's art no gear is going to
survive that how come they can't create
gear strong enough you just can't
what about like on your helmet some sort
of spray that clears the smoke out so
you can see better nothing that's not
possible
nothing that's not possible so literally
if I'm going if I'm inside of a building
on fire if you put your hand up above
your head you'll burn your hand like
it's that hot you know
so the Huayra fire gets the lower and
lower and lower you just have to get
that's why I think higher I mentioned
like yeah there's been situations where
you're pinned to the floor
I want to say pin to the floor I mean
literally like you're on your belly
because if you go up to three feet
you're going to burn if you don't carry
people out how do you get them out of it
drag them out dragon yes you gotta drag
them out grab them by I mean
there's a bunch of fancy things you can
do with straps and tools and but in the
reality of it when it's actually going
down heat at the moment you're grabbing
whatever you can and just dragging them
out what about dogs yeah we track dogs
by their legs usually dodging grab them
just calm when you drag somebody's body
is are you kind of what about their head
and stuff hitting stuff or whatever I
mean at that point yeah it just says you
really don't have it's not a situation
where them hitting their head is going
to be their problem no problem is during
a fire right so realistically yes you
try and accommodate for all those things
and you know try not to add any more
injury to anybody but I ever had a drag
Simmons body who was a bit too heavy to
drag by herself
yeah generally speaking it's tends to be
a two to four person operation I mean no
yeah yeah it's not it's not easy to drag
somebody out specially when you're on
your hands and knees yeah headsets to
talk to the other other firemen that are
in the in the building or not yell not
in the fire yeah you just yell yeah well
we have actually we have microphones on
the outside of our masks so no voice
amplifier in our microphone it's a voice
amplifier you're trying to get people
out of the building or people ever in
sort of embarrassing kind of situations
- right like a fire like naked not naked
or right up or yet Ida wearing some kind
of leather outfit or something you see a
lot of weird things that's for sure yeah
sometimes I mean what's what's one of
the weirdest things you've seen or
something or something like that or
embarrassing I mean you name it we've
seen it you know we have areas that like
you've seen someone handcuffed to the
bed yes straight up yeah and what you do
on handcuffs on their weight with a key
to jiff they snap it off with pliers no
just what the key but and were they
completely naked and around yeah yeah
they had a low blood sugar and they
passed out but it was very a fire no I
was running medical well in a way it
calls it a calling point they call the
fire department because because they
were they were hang up to the bed low
blood Sugar's a low blow job your camera
conscious
so well so someone tied them to the bed
and then and then that person that was
tied up passed out and then that person
that tied them up called called you guys
because it what did they say did they
say listen I was doing this thing it was
just a science project who just what do
they say you know I mean they make it
but usually people get embarrassed about
things just like everything in life
right but uh I mean you just comfort
them in whatever way it's I'm not we're
not there to judge okay but but but do
you guys ever kind of joke around about
it after when you're back at the bunks
yeah you might make a joke about it
later we're all human beings right there
why is it funny yeah way around that no
damn so you just walked in and they're
just tied up making this well is it easy
to meet women because of being a
firefighter is that like an attractive
thing for women as far as dating goes
yeah I would say definitely it's
probably attracted to women general you
know the whole I guess I mean it's a
good job you know you make you make
decent money you get to help people
every day so I think inherently women
are drawn to people who were doing good
and I'm not an alpha males probably
right yeah so in that regard
yeah I'd say firemen are definitely and
if it is it tempting to like wear your
shirt to a party
no come on out at all you know give me
but but you're obviously you're probably
not afraid to say that what you do for a
living it's actually kind of funny you
mention that because kind of a running
joke is you always tell them like you're
like a trash guy or something like that
really yeah I mean Oh again it's I'm
also not trying to date somebody who
wants me for my badge you know what I
mean
huh oh do you usually you don't usually
say you're a firefighter now meet
somebody I'll have to say I work for the
city or whatever well no kidding at one
point though like if you're hanging out
in two hours it's usually it's usually
your frame that throws it out there you
know that's actually kind of a nice book
do you have a designated friend to do
that
no yeah don't shout it you guys would
have parties together oh yeah you guys
go out after it when you're not working
you guys hang out all you still hang out
ya know when you're not working parties
we do a lot of activities together we
have like okay say you will mountain
bike trip snowboarding true
so we go out to the desert ride dirt
bikes we go to Las Vegas I mean there's
there's a bunch of stuff even though
it's not you know I guess not kosher or
whatever just like tell someone what you
do do is it okay for someone in your
department to say it for you
you know in not saying not revealing
their selves but then I mean put it for
the purpose of just getting it out there
- at some point I mean you can't you
know they're not going to lie to
somebody all right so if they buy they
pride and it's coming out so whatever
and you usually notice sort of a
pleasing look on their face when they
find out the truth I depends on the
person some some women don't like
firemen really oh really they had a bad
experience probably but what are some
times are women kind of just did today
do you see their eyes get bigger and
they go wow sometimes yeah absolutely
yeah and what's it what is it like with
more women working for as firefighters
as time goes on how did how does certain
men are certain men not into that or
what I'd say definitely some of the
older guys an apartment because women
really haven't joined the fire service
in larger numbers until last you know 20
20 years or so so the whole female
firefighter thing is definitely kind of
new yes some of the older guys are not
into it I'll tell you the bigger problem
for us right now is actually the whole
millennial oh yeah yeah what about it um
we tend to see a lot more people that
are failing out of our academies they're
actually they don't work as hard they
tend to be a lot more entitled and and
our job you can't be entitled like you
have to love your craft and study it
because you love your craft and and I
think that over the last few years we're
seeing an abundance of people who don't
want to work hard and go the extra mile
because it's like everything right you
could say hey take this book read it
memorize what's in it and you got the
job okay cool
that's only phase one if you're going to
continue to progress and become like an
advanced fireman with
you know a greater skill set well you
have to put in a lot of your own work I
mean we have to know how buildings are
designed how they're built all the
different areas of construction these
are all things that you have to
continuously study your craft right well
it seems like a lot of the newer members
don't have that passion to or that drive
to actually go out and put the extra
work in this makes me take it to
questions well the ones related to
earlier but when you fraternize with
your unit do you find it easy to
fraternize with the female firefighters
or is it a different kind of and only
well it's the same it's I actually uh I
find it easier and I see I find the
women that had been hired in the last
few years on our department at least I'd
rather work with them and a lot of the
guys have been hired to be honest with
you but you and you were able to joke
with them in the same way and it's the
same now about when it comes to younger
younger members is there that kind of is
there any kind of hazing almost or
anything like that or you know what
there used to be uh some of that stuff
but it's all kind of gone away nowadays
what is some of the hazing this is well
like get getting them hosed and stuff
yeah dropping buckets water on them off
the roof stuff like that I mean all that
kind of stuff you should go on but it's
really the fire service is changing a
lot they're not a much like Society yeah
they're cutting down they're being
pretty strict about that they're being
very strict did you get hey no did I get
hazed I wouldn't call it hazing just
call it more initiation right you got
initiated yeah well that's the other
thing is part of applying stress to
somebody right that's what we'll call it
joking with them giving them a hard time
those are all things that you do to
apply stress to an individual to see
kind of how they're going to react since
we don't have fires every day you have
to find other ways to apply a stress to
somebody like even dropping water on
somebody off the roof right some people
would say well that's kind of stupid why
would you do that to somebody well it
also teaches you to look up every time
you walk out of the building and looking
up is part of that look at the power
lines right there on ladders so
there's kind of like a method to the
madness some people don't understand but
you know unfortunately nowadays you
can't you can't get away with that kind
of stuff would they the sort of applying
stress process for younger people in the
past was it all kind of somewhat related
in a sort of mr. Miyagi kind of way to
firefighting or was some of it just
totally just them just messing with them
and I even related you know like sure
like toilet stuff you know although I'm
sure that applies in some way to X it is
kind of if you want to call mr. Miyagi
stuff there is a method to all of it
right there's a reason behind all of it
but at the end of the day like
everything some people take it too far
and we don't create well what's too
taken too far are I mean taking it too
far as when you're literally demeaning
somebody without reason I mean not
demeaning somebody period is wrong you
know kind of the general saying is if
they're [ __ ] with you it's because
they like you you know I mean so if
someone's not doing well and they're
struggling in there when your probation
you kind of leave them alone you back
off of them because you really need them
to focus as much as possible right what
someone's doing really well then you
continue adding jokes and stress and all
that kind of stuff to kind of see how
they react to those types had anybody
ever because of sort of the hazing ish
kind of period has they ever dropped out
because of that that was too much for
them um in the past there has only been
I mean I've had a rookie every year
since after I got off probation and I've
only had two people quit and they quit
for not because of that as other outside
family stuff or whatever you know do
people ever quit because of a traumatic
thing that happens while they were in
the line of oh I'd say there's a very
small number of people that actually
figure out they're scared and don't like
to fire claustrophobic and all that kind
of stuff but that's what the Fire
Academy is for the Fire Academy is to
test all of that and anybody but that's
why we have the Academy right so you go
through the Academy and if you can't cut
the mustard you get basically like a
long Academy
our Academy is a point system so you're
only allowed 110 points and then you
actually are let go uh-huh
is that for written exams and physical
skills testing so every test that you
take you you know you get scored and
based off of your score safety mistakes
or written question mistakes or whatever
then you actually accrued points and
throughout that whole forum on the
process you pretty much point yourself
out do you think being a firefighter is
more physically demanding than being a
police officer uh no their load they're
just different do you guys have a what's
your guys relationship with the police
department our relationships really good
actually
um we have a very strong relationship I
mean we go on calls together all the
time so we work with each other side by
side constantly there's never rivalries
between that I mean in a in a friendly
kind of way you know what I mean guys
ever have I don't know I mean I think
ball games and stuff and stuff like that
or do Meyer versus police yeah you guys
do that oh yeah well I mean we've been
on calls where we showed up and a cop
was actually you know fighting with
somebody and we went in there and
actually grabbed the guy off the cop you
know oh nice oh we help each other out
physically grab him or he lost oh wow
that was the cop like thanks guys oh
absolutely yeah I wish I wish my own my
own team was if you're that tank well
that's just you know the cops we show up
as a crew right there's a minimum of
four of us on a fire engine or fire
truck so when we show up you have four
bodies right now whereas a cop shows up
depayne what city they work for it's one
person so if they get into it with
somebody obviously one-on-one if they're
bigger that's a problem right so you
have to deal with crime stuff sometime
all the time on a regular bit and have
you come in physical contact with
someone okay I don't either
Oh what do you have to go well yeah
that's the deal I mean we have two
people swing on us believe it or not
yeah yeah you'll walk in a situation
where someone's on drugs meth out of
their mind or you know or just alter
from low blood sugar or whatever and
people get violent so I've never gotten
that that axe you ever use the Ackley's
my axe on every fire oh really
yeah not for people lobbyists pretty
head
yeah kid breaking doorways it acts heavy
ah no not really this probably like 15
pounds is it what does have their own
axe yes is it years a specialized lack
same way a max the day I got hired I
went out bought one oh really
so you're by your own axe oh yeah is
they don't you have do you have anything
engraved on and everything I just got my
name like on the top of it do you guys
have nicknames for each other nicknames
yeah oh yeah oh yeah okay really oh yeah
because I feel like I've seen that in
fire movies you know yeah everyone's got
kind of yeah every all got I mean yeah
it's like being with your cousin's your
buddies you know you call each other
stupid names yeah it sticks usually uh
when somebody says some in the room
laughs then you'll pretty much stuck
with that name you know uh-huh
do you like your name and was it given
to you by somebody else I've got lots of
nicknames
oh really do you ever want to buy a new
wax I know nicer one like a not really
ever connect better they do actually a
few years ago there's a company and they
came out with like a newly designed ax
lighter weight no you don't want to
light it right out oh you want to yeah
you want a heavy obviously to break
things or whatever but but does your
honor like the angles of it is a little
different you want a little ax to like
no to have extra no if you're going to
use your axe you want go big yeah go big
or go home would you keep the axe
all right on the hip did it I mean like
when you're not using it
oh it's just right next to you on the
rig so when you get for Bill we call
them for structure fire or any other
kind of fire you pretty much throw the
axe bolts on if your vids in a leather
axe belt have you ever been asleep and
the bell rang is it a bell that rings
that wakes you guys up we have like an
alerting system but yeah what's feel
it's not like a - you know like I know
there's like a kinda there's like a
little box on the on ceiling and in each
room and different colors for different
rigs the red ones for the engine the
green one is for the truck blue ones for
the rescue so that thing will actually
just turn on and it'll be twice for
anything other than a fire if it's a
fire that's why they call them four
bells because it beats four times it's
loud oh yeah and have you ever been
dreaming and you just get woken up and
you're just you kind of still thinking
about some crazy dream you had and but
you're kind of trying to focus on
you know it happens all the time I mean
even if you sleep in like a different
room than you're used to and you come
out the door like your body when you're
in the middle of the night it's
programmed to be a certain thing right
so my room usually I come out of my door
and I make a right and I make my way
down hallway well if I sleep in the
opposite side I've made a right and ran
right into somebody just because no
really you need somebody well I'm like a
salmon going does that happen a lot when
people are a little disoriented because
of searches are local I mean think about
it you work three days in a row and then
you have one day off and you work three
days in a row I mean we're we're one of
the biggest battles we face and life
really is just constantly being tired
because we work in busy areas and so
you're up all night how many and then in
a week how many ships do you have
usually well it's like one week every
other day and then four days off and
then a week every other day and it's six
days off so it rotates back and forth
but again you work extra days I do you
get much sleep when you're during a
shift no another time
so you are you working off of one two
hours of sleep sometimes or something
all on a regular base oh really okay is
there one or two hours there's there's
days where you you'll be basically been
up for like three four days but people
ever get into regional because of that
you feel that way sometimes but the
thing is with fires especially or like
any kind of serious emergency you get a
little bit of an adrenaline rush so that
kind of straightened you out you know
but firemen actually suffer four times
the cancer risk of most people well
because of the entire stuff and heart
attacks and everything else our lack of
sleep and all the stuff that we come
across smoke wise you have a much higher
rate of illness than most people do you
get no kind of small sicknesses a lot or
what oh I'm cold I mean I were exposed
to colds and flus every day so yeah but
rundown quite a bit you know oh you see
firefighters do get sick a lot
oh yeah I'd say it's I mean are they
sick most of the time I would say most
of the time but you're just in contact
with people with every kind of disease
and sickness you could think of every
day so and you don't have and you don't
have a lot of sleep right yeah so you
just you get rundown you know are there
things that firefighters
do like take emergency and stuff or we'd
actually have it as a staple item and at
our station you have a whole drawer full
of it your eyes eyes I can well when one
guy gets sick in the station we try and
like quarantine him a little bit so
really get out of here go to your room
you know stay in your room we don't want
to deal with you but yeah generally
speaking one guy gets it that guy get it
big if you guys kind of tell him to go
to his room did he get sad no one wants
to hang out who carries in his room
that's his problem
do you guys have Zicam do you guys use
that uh not really I mean some guys do
his personal thing whatever are there so
are there any guys who are just immune
to everything and they just seemed
bulletproof uh yeah but that's
are you ever kind of thinking what's up
with this guy he just seems like a
almost like a robot or something yeah we
got a few those guys like like what's up
to that either they never get sick a
good at everything and you know like you
saw the [ __ ] why are you excited
everything you do and those guys like
that are they what are they humble or
they not or well that's that's
person-to-person basis I know that's
just a personality thing it's just that
society you know some people are
homeless or not I'd say my department
specifically is a more humble type of
culture you know in general it's one of
those things where I think if you work
for a real busy fire department you
don't have anything approved because you
work you go to fire so you do your job
and I guess if you work for a smaller
fire department sometimes you know you
don't actually get to fight as much fire
and stuff like that so but what's what's
one of your most proudest moments
fighting fires my proudest moments I
never even thought about that before I
mean is there any there's a particular
time you can think of that you felt
really fulfilled and particularly
fulfilled
I mean ticularly like something you felt
some sort of sense of realism well yeah
I mean I would say in general when you
actually save somebody you know that's
was there any particular saving of
somebody in particular that sticks out
on your mind no I've had a couple and
they're all kind of the same you know
when you actually we trained to do this
job to save people's lives at the end of
the day
so when you actually are able to perform
a job and actually save somebody's life
it's pretty awesome you know we had we
had a guy who actually crashed in a
plane and three of the other people are
deceased but we pulled one guy out and
I'd say actually that was one of my
pottery moments yeah we pulled a guy out
we cut the plane open what kind of plane
was it it was a smaller like kini air
like private aircraft yeah and after
cutting the plane open and getting him
out I mean I thought there's no way this
guy's gonna live you know he is hanging
on by a thread we were breathing for him
but what was he what was wrong with what
did he have going on that was I mean his
entire skull was exposed Wow it was like
a big cap that kind of cut off his head
multiple broken bones and injuries and
punctured lungs you name it he had it
we actually six months later got to meet
him his whole family so Wow oh my god
that was pretty awesome he was actually
up and walking and talking to us how old
is he uh he was probably in his 50s was
it super emotional yeah they were pretty
emotional yeah do you get emotional and
stuff like that um I mean not really I
think most of us their firefighters tend
to kind of bottle up our emotions quite
a bit you know I don't think it's not
really the kind of job where you can be
outwardly emotional if we got emotional
about every call we went on it'd be a
big problem you know I've had a couple
calls uh mostly with children that you
know they remind me of my niece or
nephew I had a second was like kind of
stunned like oh my god you know like the
firemen cry I'm sure they do yeah I mean
she had all that bravery to it have you
ever seen someone cry because of
something yeah oh really yeah when we go
on particularly difficult calls we have
we call CISD team critical incident
stress debriefing so when we're going
really like really gnarly calls
generally speaking those units will go
out of service and have a special team
especially trained peers that will
actually sit in a room and talk about it
and you know kind of get it all out on
the table because we're not real
outwardly emotional right so that's
created these teams
I mean I can't talk to somebody who
hasn't done my job about we're going
through right so that's why we've
trained our peers who mutually we do the
same job we know if he's asking me a
question I know that he's done the same
job that's it yeah um what's what's a
really gnarly situation um like a little
kid that fell out of a third-story
window and smacked right on her head you
know three years old it's just stuff
like that you're you know it's it's a
mess you show up on scene there's people
everywhere losing their minds you know
the parents are losing their mind what
are you supposed to do in that case
what's your job in that situation well
realistically our job is not really to
save people per se it's more to keep
them alive to get them to the hospital
because when somebody seriously injured
like that what they need is a doctor
they need emergency surgery our job is
to keep them alive long enough to
deliver them to the emergency room so
they can get the care that they really
need so in that situation we call it
diesel that's what they really need we
need to scoop that person up get them in
the ambulance we do have some
medications and some we do perform
certain things to keep them alive oh you
do - yeah uh-huh
and then we get into the hospital and
then obviously from there do you ever
drive the truck yeah oh you do it is
every member of the team have to know
how to do every part of every kind of
job every department is a little bit
different but there is a captain there's
an engineer and then use your
firefighters right well your captain is
obviously the guy in charge with the Red
Hat the engineers the guy that actually
drives and that's a promotional position
so over six years or four years as a
fireman you can actually take the test
for engineer is that a sought-after
position yeah I mean it's a promotion
yeah it's stressful to be driving like
that siren on cut through and absolutely
there's someone steering the back of it
- yeah that's currently that's what I do
now um you know in our station we have
an engineer a truck company it's called
the Tillerman actually tiller many
tillers the truck he drives the back of
it so
the fireman at my station we rotate
through if the fire truck ever kind of
swinging back and for all time it is
okay yeah yeah the reason they do that
is you know you see a big rig pull out
onto a street make a turn just got to go
super wide right well that's why the
wheels of a big truck we can turn the
back so we can cut short corners and
stuff like I'm gettin in alleyways it's
an access thing I mean is there any
element element of it that makes you
feel like you're playing a video game
when you're driving the truck was
driving a video - the - yeah the tiller
I'm not gonna lie it's pretty damn fun
to be back there is it really oh yeah
are you listening to music or is it more
like yeah we have we have a stereo but
it's really not that loud because we're
listening to our dispatch yeah yeah all
the time
what kind of music is playing depends on
who's driving okay say you're the
Tillerman or whatever
well it's called Tillerman the other
Tillerman yeah the Tillerman does yeah I
don't I listen to whatever's in the cab
because that's what's playing over all
of our headsets okay yeah so whoever's
driving tends to pick the music what do
they pick usually you name it they pick
it you know everything all alignment
like east to country music you know it's
across the board yeah I'm we get we got
guys that are from every walk of life
all parts of society it's a very diverse
group would you like to be driving the
front at one point that's not something
that it's all engineer uh-huh originally
I wanted to I had kind of like a plan
laid out you know ten years as a fireman
and five years engineer but I've
actually decided I don't think I'm going
to do that position only because one of
the engineer you can't go inside on
fires for the most part that's a pole
but you can't go in no because you're
the guy that actually controls all you
actually you control your hose yes
you're controlling water pressures and
who's getting water and you're like a
logistics guy or you're a
behind-the-scenes guy so you're doing
everything to make sure do you think
those jobs are better suited for foxes
wow I guess I don't know I I got one
when you get to the fire you get to a
fire the buildings on fire is there an
order who goes in first or is it just
whoever gets there more like some places
are smaller so then you would through on
the phone no actually our department has
a very it's like organized chaos we have
each position has a specific task they
need to perform so the guy that sits
behind
the captain is called the nozzle man and
then the guy that hits its in the behind
the engineer is the hydrant guy so if we
go to a fire and we need to take a
hydrant the guy in that number three
spot already knows I'm the hydrate guy
so when they stop the hydrant there
isn't even any verbal anything just say
hey take a hydrant and the ones I guess
what about going in entering the bills
anything yeah you guys have a designated
order ahead we do and the way it kind of
works is the newest member when you're
on probation you get the nozzle every
single time you're the one that pulls a
line obviously if it's a bigger line you
help the guy but when you're a new
member you're on the nozzle you're on
the tools because they want you to get
the experience once you're off probation
so they kind of throw you in when you're
new they throw you into the harder it's
all kind of yeah absolutely yeah you put
them in the busier place the nozzle is
holding the front of the hose is it hard
to hold the hose and yeah it's not it's
not easy I mean it isn't a skill if
somebody like me held the hose but I
just be what I to be thrown over I've
just made over here or something without
any training yeah oh to kick your ass
yeah obviously that I mean is it is the
hose just kind of just going crazy when
there's water going we'll I mean it's
just general if you lose your nozzle and
it's open it'll knock you out straight
up because it has anyone ever gotten hit
in the face with a nozzle
yessum for sure if they high and they've
got knocked out stitches the whole deal
Wow and how many so how many guys does
it take to hold the hose it depends on
the size so we have like an inch and
three-quarter hotline they call it which
is it's already pre connected you know
150 foot 200 foot 350 feet 250 feet we
have different size closes already pre
connected and ready so when you pull it
off and all they have to do is pull the
gate to give you water so depending on
the size of the hose not just the length
of it but it's more so diameter we'll
say the biggest hose it takes how many
men - ha
or when was actually a fire fire I mean
you could do it with three or four but
to be effective with a hose line on a
larger diameter hose line you're going
to need to companies on that oh really
yeah you so you need you need what 20
people on those competences like a typo
okay but again understand that it's one
thing if you're going in a straight line
put water on something but it's never
like that you're going around corners
and every corner you hit you need
somebody at each corner to advance that
line everybody's got to be pulling it's
in a straight say in a straight line and
you're dealing with the large largest
hose you think like I mean not think but
you usually use eight Thursday 8 guys
even holding that know if you're just
holding the hose and you should
definitely do a couple yeah but have you
ever done how we fire fire
you know I've ever been thrown off
balance because of the hose yeah but
I've never like lost the hose line or
anything like what huh you know it
happens this is the host Gary no well
it's not huh and it hoses the least of
your problems when you're in a fire
Robby I'll fix the tube house what how
thick inch and 3/4 that's such a not
that big gosh look at that mauler one oh
no big is this the big larger one is two
and a half inches that still seems well
I guess that seems pretty every talk
about this stream yeah I mean oh you
thought about it that's the width of you
as a host so I mean you're looking at
like you know 250 gallons of water per
minute yeah do you do you want to be a
captain yeah I do that's sort of the
next step for you that is going to be my
next step crab huh yeah I'm actually
going to start setting for that I'm
going to start setting for now for the
next test it should be like year half
did so because you get thrown into the
hardest stuff first
does the job get easier well also job
obviously gets easier probably through
experience but right does it also does
your position get a little easier to as
time it does like everything you do in
life right when you do something on a
regular basis you get better at it
yeah but I mean aside from that is just
even your job as not as is demanding
maybe as well as you get as you get
higher up on in the world of soar that's
the thing it no it's always demanding
it's always difficult because what we do
is never the same right no two fires are
the same we constantly see things that
you're like oh my you know and you draw
on experiences from other calls and
other situations to handle it so it's
that's kind of part of the thing about
being a fireman too
is it's constantly a new challenge and
something new you know
the majority of what we do medical calls
a heart attacks on heart attack so we
have you know you get better at those
things it just becomes why is the fire
department called for medical calls and
why not paramedics or whatever well we
are the government oh you are oh yeah
that's the other thing people don't tend
to realize especially here in Southern
California the West Coast actually in
the United States is kind of at the
forefront of the fire service as far as
being more of an always department so we
do all medicals that's part of your job
to come before you're a paramedic also
I'm not a paramedic but I work with the
paramedics on I recall so when you
become a fireman at some point usually
they will send you a paramedic school so
all paramedics were firemen at some
point they're still firemen it's just
the difference is this they basically
are able to administer drugs
whereas I cannot administer a drug to
somebody because I haven't got a
paramedics all the other skills though
or is something that you have to write
yeah we're all we're all emergency
medical technicians we're all trained to
the medical level but we don't actually
push drugs the paramedics push the drugs
I don't want to be a medic because then
you have to run an ambulance I mean you
have to write on an ambulance and you
don't get to be on nozzle and you don't
get to be on the roof cutting a hole in
it so right I want to play fireman I
don't want you guys yeah is it hard to
plug the hose into the fire hydrant no
it's not too hard you screw right on one
of the tools you got on your with you
instead of the actaully clariah a
variety hand tools like all kinds of we
have a couple different kinds of pliers
screwdrivers because again like we're
not just going to fires right we're
going to car accidents when people can't
shut off the water you know you have to
know about water heaters and plumbing
and electrical and everything else you
prefer to have fire calls right over the
medical calls yeah of course yeah I mean
that's what that's that's the best
number one passion yeah right it's about
the a fire fire by the way that I wanted
to ask you earlier has anyone ever
accidentally fallen down the the pole
roll broken legs oh really yeah so
especially he grabbed that thing with
wet hands
there's no stoppin uh-huh and has anyone
ever sort of human being kind of
disoriented because they were just
sleeping accidentally just sort of
walked right into the hole I wouldn't
say they've actually walked into it
they're very specific it's like it's
literally a room you know it's got funny
I did my first ride-along with the
Glendale Fire Department actually when I
was an EMT and in training I wasn't
farming it so I go upstairs I put all my
stuff in the room and I'm just I'm just
a civilian writing along and they get a
call and the guy knocks on my door he's
like hey man hit the pole I was like
pull I walk out of the door literally
there's a door that says Pole hole and
you open it oh wow oh there's a door for
it so it's not just an open thing no
there's like a little room where when
you go through that door you know that's
what you're going is that is going down
the pole kind of scary no it's awesome
how high is it it just seems to story ah
the biggest one we have is probably 25
feet there's actually a two level one
you have to drop one down by one and
then go over and drop down is there a
way you you switch over to a different
pole is there a ping-pong table in that
room there is a ping-pong table of that
station actually we're going back to the
pole is it do people ever burn their
hands or anything or the yeah if you
ever hit any kind of like nothing's
fiction burns yeah I'm not that serious
I mean usually use your foot on the pole
to slow you down yeah and how do you
clean your how do you do dry clean your
fire suit or how does that work our fire
suit you know we have special washers
for them okay yeah they're called
extractors but it's a special how many
suits again I'm on my third set of
turnouts they call it their cold
turnouts is anyone ever have any kind of
OCD kind of stuff I'm the in the
department yeah of course I mean do they
ever get into a place say it's a medical
call or whatever they got maybe ours
anyone ever kind of germ germaphobic and
stuff all there's a ton of germaphobes
now really well how do they deal with
doing the job you know wash your hands
constantly uh-huh people ever guys
certain guys ever weird about you know
like say sliding on the pole after all
these other guys have slid down the pole
there's it like again the fire service
is a snapshot
so yeah you've got people that freaked
out about everyone got their little IDEO
sequency idiosyncrasies that they've got
their you know like when I show up for
work I have a very specific process I
meet everything in its exact place so
that if you kind of OCD to a little bit
I'm not certain I organized a yeah when
it comes to like the firefighting aspect
of it we have to be that way with our
gear because you have to be fire ready
at all times it could not put back the
same way in the same position every
single time it's because of waking up in
the middle of the night going to use a
tool you pretty much program yourself to
make sure that everything is always the
same and that's part of you know rote
memory does anyone ever disinfect get
like what disinfectant wipes on say the
pole or whatever before we clean the
pole once a week
polishes brass so it gets polished once
a week no I mean the majority guys are
not germaphobes but yeah there's always
a couple you ever have visitors at the
station mm-hmm yeah a family's family
friends yeah my nieces and nephews my
sisters and yeah teachers were just out
my fire station with my answers last
weekend but are you kind of thinking you
that you don't want people to really
visit you because you have to sleep and
stuff no we love having busy yeah do you
guys are how often very family-oriented
environment I mean it's pretty much your
second family so how long are right
along so know how easy it is to do a
Riedel is pretty easy
any call you can call up any
headquarters of any fire department and
request right along is it dangerous to
be doing it right oh now I would say so
I don't owe you do it can you sit at the
near the Tillerman when you're not in a
right element and let's get on unless
your training there's an actual seat
that attaches to the outside of it so
you said outside and the guy training is
next to him is there a ladder guy who
deals with the ladder the fireman
through all the letters on the big truck
the engineer he throws the ladder like
the big hunter foot area ladder
he's the one that actually will throw it
to a bill are there any any fights that
break out between firefighters there
have been in the past
just personalities clashing you know
definitely there's you know it's like
everything else you got personality
conflicts and problems and guys
move to different stations sometimes and
I would say it's not the norm but it
does have have you ever had any beef
with anybody in your unit ah like sure I
have I was thrown have you guys fun
no not because it's just a shower you
know just yeah ever after a case like
even like how they handled something and
afterwards you're out in the lawn nears
it's a very very men Adam we're a very
vocal group so our our department again
we kind of pride ourselves in being you
know professionals and part of that is
you get called out on your mistakes so
when you screw something up everybody
knows and the peer pressure is part of
the drive to get better and continuously
do your job well because you don't want
to let your team members down that's
part of the deal you're part of the team
so if you if one guy screws up the
operation he's screwing everybody else
over so that's part of the drive to make
sure you do everything the way are
supposed to do you guys think of
yourselves sometimes like a sports team
or something that is essentially
question definitely I truly feel that
we're like basically professional
athletes I mean we here I'm so glad we
have to work out constantly like you
know people joke the firemen sit around
you work out well we do but when you're
there for 24 hours you have to you have
to be in shape there's a gym a trellis
to the fire station we do we have a gym
it is everyone on in the unit like an
athlete at some point where were they at
not everybody would athlete I was not an
athlete but that's because my high
school career didn't involve sports and
involved it and screwing off pretty much
so I started fires maybe yeah but I but
I've been in sports you know growing up
and I'm a mountain biker and a surfer or
the snowboarder and all that kind of
stuff right yeah our job is very
physically demanding but also just even
the way you're going to attack a
situation you have us almost like a play
right yeah well we do it somewheres and
since I've been with my my crew for
eight years like it's like an organized
it's literally me and the other firemen
we're working together we just look at
each other because we know each other so
well it's like a dance you just operate
around each other and your to know it's
a system it just works you know who's is
there a coach
kind of like it's the captain the
captain would be is there someone
Poseidon's like the dad Edwin fire
stations how old is a captain usually it
varies I'd say anywhere from like early
30s to you know 50 who is there's an
older person at the station that's not
the captain that's yeah yeah there's I
don't they don't go on to the jobs that
they're there no I mean there's always a
senior guy at every fire station the guy
who's been there the longest time on the
job is pretty big thing with us what's
higher than the captain ah
battalion chief what is it go a
battalion chief what's higher than that
chief our regular chief you have deputy
chiefs assistant Chiefs and then the
fire chief so so how old is a chief
usually I'd say in chief generally
speaking like late 40s mid to late 40s
plus when does when does a firefighter
retire well you can retire at 50 but to
get to maximize your retirement you have
to put 30 years in on the job so oh do
you like your chief next question my
battalion chief is awesome uh-huh our
actual fire chief it's just tough those
guys are in a spot where they you know
they're basically politicians at that
point and they're you know they got the
City Council to deal with their job is
different they're not firemen is there
is there are there any Chiefs that wind
up in that position who never didn't go
through all the steps of being a
firefighter yes there definitely I mean
it's like everything right so if you
become a fireman and you work at busy
fire stations your whole career you
develop certain a certain amount of
respect from your peers right oh that
guy's done it
he knows his job he's dialed in he's
very good at it and then there's guys
who basically just promote and skip
steps don't put their time in and really
just it's just a different is it
possible to get a cheap position without
even having working fire before well not
without having worked in fire no you
have to be a fireman but you can be a
fireman at a slow place and not study
your craft and you could be a shitty
fireman basically and still promote
because the promotional exam is it's a
test you know you could study for a test
you can't study for the job does that
make sense
you know you're good at your job because
you're doing it or you suck at it
because you don't really care about your
job that much to people you know how you
described yourself as Bad News Bears
right yeah do other fire departments
look at you guys like that I would say
definitely some people like I'll give an
example I went to a class in San Diego
for urban search and rescues like a
trench rescue class whatever and there
was 15 of us on our department in this
class there's like 15 from your unit
that was there 15 from our fire
department in this class like 50 people
anymore well one of the guys there was
actually my captain okay but the first
two days of class there's no safety gear
out you're just in your regular civilian
clothes
well we were giving each other a hard
time in class and you're you know being
kind of obnoxious I suppose and then
third day you put all your gear on and
one of the guys like that guy's your
captain I was like yeah why be like I
can't believe you talk to him like that
I was like well what do you mean he's
like dude I would be written up for
speaking like captain like that so
that's it's a different culture for us
you know for us it's like we're all just
grown men on a team and we work together
but a lot of places it's very
militaristic so it's sir yes sir sore
nose oh really
grab the wall your your your departments
pretty just relaxed it's a little bit
more relaxed yeah our departments more
focused around so some of them are women
some of them have to say sir yes sir
yeah a lot of departments are that way
like even if your friend for most the
captain the next day when he shows up
the station you have to be like captain
so it's all you know uh-huh
which is not a fireman be like no that's
not going to fly so you're a captain you
just call them gym or whatever his name
is yeah yeah exactly yeah it's just yeah
if you like them by captain yes yeah
I've been very fortunate all the
counselors that I've worked for been
very very good good captain so I've
learned a lot from is there any cool
there's corruption in police departments
sometimes is there any kind of
corruption and fire departments and and
it's not really and if there was how
would that play out exactly what you
know what kind of things could you know
eh 80 firefighters really there really
isn't to be on
has ever been a firefighter who starts
fires himself just to fight him you know
there was there was a guy I'd really
worked for Glendale Fire John or I
believe is his name and he was actually
an arson no kidding his job was arson
investigator and the way they caught him
was he was lighting fires lowdown crazy
the way okay so he would start the fires
in right so that he could put him out
yeah
Wow well he didn't actually put him out
because he was not part of operations he
was an arson investigator huh former
firemen you know we have different
things within the department fire
prevention
why was he starting these fires because
he was just an artist he's an artist
yeah that was his job was arson and he
was an arsonist and the way they caught
him was there was a conference up north
in Northern California and they noticed
this pattern somebody finally noticed a
pattern that every time they had a
conference fires would be lit all along
that corridor and all the way back so
someone finally put it all together and
they caught him he's in jail still today
Wow
so what I was asking is is there a guy
is there any had you ever seen somebody
who starts fires so they could fight
them because he with their board or not
board or but there I mean I've never
kind of challenged there so I've never
been across anyone like that but it does
happen actually have everybody in the
force that happens quite well actually
have you ever done something to
challenge yourself in a safe environment
have you ever started a fire in order to
practice putting it out oh we we have
actual live burns that we do so we like
we like we have a special building at
our training center and we do live burns
on a regular basis how do you think our
live burns are actually better than some
of our regular fires a lot of time oh
really
oh yeah I mean we light them up for you
you look forward to that oh yeah anybody
is that pretty fun just have the
opportunity to start fires it is awesome
because when you do actually do
controlled burns like that there's
different positions where you can
actually monitor the fire and watch the
fire from like an outsider looking in
and watch the kree's coming in so you
can learn a lot just a lot of benefit to
doing that how well do you think the
media portrays fire horribly so all
movies
um what would ya like firefighters
saying that movie backdraft it's got
it's funny it's kind of a joke I mean
it's not it's not reality you know I
mean it's really not reality I remember
my mom calls me one day she was watching
that show Chicago Fire and she's like a
little Victor do you guys really have to
solve people's arms off if they're
trapped under something I'm like oh yeah
use it all the time he saws all peoples
arms off she's like oh my god I'm like
mom I'm joking no we don't cut people's
arms off we move the object so I think
the way that we're play charades
we're portrayed people just don't
realize the amount of stuff that we do
and the amount of Education and the
level of training then we go through
like like you guys earlier were just
like wait you're a paramedic I mean we
would don't understand like when you
call 9-1-1 you get the fire department
doesn't matter what the thing is or what
the problem is you know it doesn't
matter if it's an earthquake a broken
pipe in your house but when you get you
call 911 go to the fire department first
or technically goes through CHP I
believe but yet you get when you call
number one you get the fire department
and the police department that's who
goes to a boat yeah okay yeah I mean it
varies a little bit depending on where
in the United States you are right but
here in California we got a pretty
advanced system so yeah mm-hmm didn't
call us for all kinds of stuff I mean
are there any fire movies that get it
right mmm I've never seen when the kids
are right uh-huh no I mean anything they
definitely portray actually now that you
mentioned that he probably has the best
show I've ever seen on on being a
fireman yeah what was it it was on HBO's
hour-long documentary because Denis
Leary was actually New York fireman so
he was he was and he did a whole hour
long documentary and went back to his
old fire crew and I would say that is
the most OnPoint thing I've ever seen
Steve Buscemi was a firefighter do you
know who Steve Buscemi's actor I'm not
sure he's a he's in the show Boardwalk
Empire now guys are that Vietnam he if
you sound yeah kind of a that look you
know you'd see him he looks like kind of
like a sorority guy or something but
he's actually uh you know the other one
I don't know if you guys are ever seen a
documentary burn it's about the Detroit
Fire Department
so google it burn that actually is a
very good snapshot into the fire service
it's actually just a really rad
documentary about Detroit and everything
that happened to it and how they deal
with it as a city and as a department
when you're giving forest fire stuff are
you just you're by yourself usually
they're no you're never by yourself
I mean I go out on assignment by myself
like so I have some special
qualifications from when I was a forest
fireman so they'll actually call me as a
single resource to do certain jobs in
the wildland environment so you show up
there as one person but it's it's
everything is a group it's it's all a
team effort type thing mm-hmm
was it was that job kind of boring no
okay I mean being a forest farm and I
loved it I still love it you're lighting
force on fire you're flying around in
helicopters you know you're fighting
fire with fire which is pretty awesome
right now so how do you fight fire with
fire so you have to be burn operations
as a big fire is moving towards like
let's say a community you actually have
to you have to time everything perfectly
and the weather and everything has to be
within certain parameters but you
actually will put fire on the ground
around those houses and have the fire
you light drawn into the main fire and
that's how you set up a buffer so that
that big forest fire doesn't just slam
into the houses and burn them down so
there's a whole what do you use to start
that fire there's a bunch of different
tools out there a few Z's or like you
know looks like a regular road flare we
have drip torches that you actually mix
two parts to one fuel with diesel and
you just drop lines of fuel on the
ground they have hella torches so these
helicopters there's a variety of
different firing methods do you ever
have an actual gun that you should buy
or gun yeah
Oh like a flamethrower it basically not
it actually shoots like imagine lighting
like you know those safe and sane
fireworks on fire it's like that you
load it into the gun you shoot it'll fly
50 60 feet onto a mountainside have you
ever been hypnotized by fire I've never
been hit but times by fire you've ever
been just I love to turn out it though I
can watch fire all day long oh really
yeah you hired candles and or like a
little fireplace I mean that place
doesn't everybody I do yes sure baby
it's mesmerizing that I think that
are the that's part of the attraction to
it you ever watched fire videos yeah
well if you go online and just watch a
lot of fire stuff pretty regularly we
use those for training but I mean I mean
what about shaking everybody's
mesmerized by fire sure maybe maybe
firefighters more maybe there maybe more
so because we're thinking about it from
a different perspective yeah
do you ever are there any um really
artistic guys on the on your team
artistic yeah they ever do paintings of
fires yeah we do we have the fire
service again it's like literally a
snapshot by society right so we have
guys who actually do all of our designs
every station has their own actual
intricate design and oh really
yeah we have guys that are plumbers
electricians roofers are there need
firefighters that are nerds yes there's
the nerdy guy I have a got a nerdy guys
yeah so are they still tough though some
of them are some of them are so are
there wimpy guys who's the smallest guy
in your in onion in your department the
smallest guy is probably five foot three
or four what's he wearing
I put three or four and what's your way
like 120 it's probably around that he's
probably around that what does he do
well he's a definitely thought I think
fries fire like the rest of us I mean
again you have to train to a certain
level if you can't train it if you can't
physically accomplish that you don't you
get fired basically so I mean he does
the same thing we do you know it's not
about strength it's not about strength
always I mean there's a certain amount
of strength required but once you've
achieved that certain goal the stronger
you are the easier it is I would say but
you know you could either do with
finesse or brute force every goal can be
accomplished it's all about what you're
having a tool bag and how you do it
right so if I'm going to go through that
door I can kick it down with my foot or
I can pick the lock what it what is a
backdraft exactly backdrops is basically
it doesn't happen as often out here
because the houses here aren't really
sealed up the way they are in the cold
areas on East Coast Midwest and stuff
but it's essentially a fire will start
and then it gets to a point where it
turns into all non combusted materials
so all those particles
Moke are basically little tiny particles
of something that hasn't burned but is
still flammable with them I'm sorry okay
can you say that one more time actually
so smoke itself the reason you can see
it is because if something burns the
heat and everything is actually carrying
tiny little particles of unburned
product right so you went in so far
unburned product one more product so
that's what smoke is that's what small
its heat carrying particles on a wooden
dress or whatever
exactly Wow okay so a lot of it that way
but that's that big reason everyone oh
yeah yeah well that's why because we get
that's why we get cancer because all the
synthetics and stuff right other so
synthetic material that's in the smoke
show exactly the wool okay I just that's
all particles of unburned to die right I
didn't even realize that about smoke
that that's what that is right
so okay going you put a fire in a room
right and it's got some material to burn
well it gets to a point where it
actually will run out of oxygen but it's
still so hot but that material is still
actually it's still burning but it's not
actively burning by flame if that makes
sense okay because it's a heat so
correct it's so hot if it's 600 degrees
in here well then this table is going to
team continue to kind of show itself out
it's the because fire needs oxygen
correct to stay alive
correct so in this is a situation where
there's no oxygen left so the fire is
out but the sheet is on correct and it's
like an oven or something it's exactly
right and then imagine all those
unburned particles are now completely
banked and compressed into this little
room so when you have that situation and
you open up a door as soon as you
introduce oxygen it's an actual
explosion oh because it's compressed in
this room so as soon as it gets to
oxygen it sucks the oxygen in so fast it
actually explodes out of the room
Wow so it's almost kind of I mean it you
know kind of reverse almost way when you
turn a gas oven on and you have to light
it yourself or whatever right it's
almost kind of like round yeah alright
you're lighting it with the oxygen
though correct
Wow and it's already it's hot enough to
ignite the only thing missing was oxygen
so yes we introduced it it's it's
explosive it literally is an explosion I
never
out of the smoke that that's what that
is it's just particles for some reason I
always thought of it as some sort of
product of the of the fire yeah I mean
it is like sly product we're looking
like a campfire for example right
there's a little bit of smoke that comes
out of it but generally speaking it's a
free burning fire the oxygen is coming
in the bottom and then some of those
particles are coming off but if you put
that same campfire in a room then all
that smoke is going to Bank down and it
will remove the oxygen so mm-hmm have
you ever had a backdraft situation I
have not No
I hope I never do those are other than
theirs that's a worst thing that could
happen in a situation I mean it's not
any variety of things that can happen in
a fire falling down I mean is that is
that what it fires most or fire
situation is most dangerous is that
dress the backdrop of flashover
what's a flashover a flashover is so you
take that same fire you put it in a room
there is a path for oxygen to come in
but inevitably the fire is going to move
faster than they can pull oxygen in
right so as that smoke and heat starts
to bank down into a room it's literally
like a ceiling like you could put your
head to the floor and look straight
across the room but if you go up two
feet you can't see anything because it's
Bank down it's all stratified in the
environment there well a flashover is
when that entire area above you ignites
simultaneously just in one shot
everything just lights off at the same
time and all fires actually burn that
way she is a small fire in any
environment enclosed environment we'll
start off as a small fire and then it'll
actually build itself up the smoke and
the heat will start to Bank down and
eventually the fire will spontaneously
ignite across the entire room so just if
the fire just fills the room pretty much
out in one shot Wow the entire ceiling
of smoke just ignites at one time do you
think fire is just so crazy yeah I do
I'm not I find it fascinating
yeah I'm part of fighting fire is
actually knowing at what level that
rooms at and you have to obviously if
you reach flashover and you're in that
room your chances of surviving are very
small mm-hmm so that's part of the deal
right is you have to go
on and put the fire out before you reach
flashover yeah really Haiti was yeah
please do go could I go for a bunch of
your everybody nightmares about this
kind of thing
nightmares oh it's a copiers about
cockroaches
oh dear Eddie he had a lot purchase no
but a lot of the houses we go onto or
filled with them I had a lot of two-inch
cockroach stuck in my turnouts once
during a little fun stuck in your what
in my turnouts like it was crawling
around its to turn out turn outs of the
gear that you see us wear
okay we're into the fryer there was a
lump in it it was in there yeah it
crawled all the way up and onto my arms
calm it was inside it was it would crawl
up your leg or something like that oh my
goodness that's horrific ever since then
I can't stand cockroaches oh we go we go
on calls all the time obviously in the
lower-income area you go into houses
where there's cockroaches and they're
pretty disgusting are they just all over
the house everywhere hundreds Wow
crawling all over the people you're
going on everything aren't your suits
kind of think I'll turn out to you they
are they kind of insulated it in a way
where there's insulation but I mean the
bugs can get in there oh yeah for sure
and again you know a lot of the places
we go to people that are unhealthy and
people who have fires tend to be a lot
of pakrac conditions yeah so a Packer
outhouse obviously has a much better
gross stuff at least houses all the time
and you see just who and stuff everyone
at the time really all the time yeah on
a regular basis yeah have you ever been
to a rat infested house many many times
what about raccoon infested not record
I've had a raccoon issues at my house
but do you ever have dude so you haven't
had nightmares about fire though uh no I
wouldn't say that I've actually had a
lot of dreams about fire like fighting
fire in my dreams yeah I can't say I've
ever actually had a nightmare where I
got stuck burning or something or we
have you ever had a dream that fire was
a monster or something there was a fire
monster or nothing like that every fire
fired every other ad was me actually
fighting fire with my buddies yeah
that's good I mean what do you smoke
cigarettes no I used to anymore the our
cigarettes I think any must say you get
a light a little mini fire every time
both cities make you sign a smoking
policy so most fire
I mean nowadays the fire services
transition to an extremely healthy deal
is it a lot of CrossFit we eat a lot
healthier than we used to the whole
thing you know I mean is it weird to
breathe you know smoke cigarette smoke
knowing knowing what smoke is all about
and and you know as fires are all about
is it not does that make it easy for
firefighters are not smoke or not I mean
being a fireman
I guess you're breathing that stuff in
it I some guys look at it the opposite
way like what is the matter for us right
right by fire awesome what does it
matter you know right and and we have a
lot of guys that get cancer a very young
age
oh yeah quite a few but that's because
of the fire smoke from the 1910s worse
now because of all the synthetic
materials and our you know couches and
all that stuff right so that makes 500
so that makes fires a lot worse yeah I
mean a synthetic couch that actually
produces hydrogen cyanide you know it's
we've got monitors gas monitors there
anything about are there any activist
firefighters who want to change the way
that you know household products are
made not really I mean business is
business money is money
we're not going to change our product
that I'd say the activism part of it is
more focused around getting firefighters
cancer coverage because a lot of cities
firemen will come down with cancer 25 30
years into their career or afterwards
and cities don't want to pay for it and
the bottom line is we're getting cancer
because of the job that we do even with
masks on and stuff it doesn't matter
that because again those incomplete
products of combustion even after the
fires out and you're doing overhaul you
know it's still you're still breeding
that stuff in you go to a car fire I
mean it's you're still breathing the
smoke at some point you know yeah and is
there anything else you use besides
water to put out fire well we use foam
as well
Oh foam what that looking like like an
Ibiza foam party it basically just
allows the water to penetrate it could
be different types of fires require
different types you know lipstick and we
have let's hear the phone is it depends
we have different forms of applications
so we can actually make it like an Ibiza
party
you know four feet of real thick foam or
you can actually it's just like an agent
added into the water when we fire fire
its water but in the overhaul process
afterwards or in flammable liquid fires
so if you have like a tank farm the
lights off you actually put a blanket of
foam on it to put it out cuz you have to
seal it off do you is there any kind of
way to put out a fire with like a fan or
something a fan I know that will spread
it probably but a fan is not good for
firing out as soon as you add more
oxygen equals a bigger fire I'm thinking
about a dust some sort what a dust dust
dust is going to be flammable okay well
they have a we have and we have some
certain you know different types of fire
extinguishers there are specific
chemicals designed to smother certain
types of fires so what are those what
are what is in this fire extinguisher it
depends on the kind of extinguisher one
of them is Halon there's there's some of
them the agents do different things so
one extinguisher actually just cuts off
oxygen from the environment another one
forms a coating over the fire so it
actually does the same thing cuts off
the oxygen and then one of them is just
water with a little bit of foam added to
it yeah how come to not giant fire
extinguishers Aqaba don't yeah like well
like gigantic ones yeah that's what we
are yes
are there any guys your group is really
tight right are there any guys who are
kind of do their own thing they don't
really fit in as much or I mean some
stations have those guys but I mean does
that not that kind of not work for when
you guys are working no well generally
speaking each crew you kind of gravitate
towards the other firemen that are kind
of like you personality-wise that's why
you've got certain houses that are like
animal houses where it's just a bunch of
dudes who are it dirty messy in these
places no we keep it super clean we I
mean it we're very organized everything
has a place like part of your morning
thing is you clean the whole fire
station we [ __ ] lawns
we do clean our stove once a week does
anyone on on is everyone pretty much on
the same schedule or okay so there's no
no one's just sort of just has a reverse
cloth or something and then they're kind
of up at the wrong hour
now everyone's pretty much the same
scare anybody sneak this no okay no
that's definitely not that's that goes
right back to like women with I sure as
all those old days of partying stuff
yeah now we're we're extremely
professional or how often did is five to
five writers have to be drug-tested
stuff
well the depends on your department like
our department if you crash a vehicle
then you get tested but there's no like
random testing for us but if you can
accidentally get tested mm-hmm alright
lenio less final thoughts on what you
have what I eat for breakfast what do I
have for breakfast this morning
or like most days at the office three
hardwoods with what by themselves just
straight up those as I'm getting older
though I'm trying to lose weight
okay are you the strongest you ever been
right now no not me stronger
yeah for sure alright I'm getting older
it's getting harder to stay in shape I
mean we're plagued with injuries it's
constant you know like I you know you
guys right I am being a basically
professional athlete we work out
everyday we our job is physically
demanding and that comes with injuries
so it's a constant the older you get
it's just an elbows off and years off
something's always you know hindering
you at some point do people take
supplements yeah what about like illegal
ones like steroid now that's just maybe
like I imagine
I imagine someone somewhere has I think
the biggest thing with the fire
department which which is really what
makes it different than every other job
or career is ultimately at the end of
the day we're probably the only group of
people who on your worst day of your
life you trust us to come into your
house right and be around your family
whatever's in your house and everything
else the amount pretty much the only
thing that is absolutely not okay
dishonesty right I think that's why a
general fireman there's no there is no
not even the cops even the cops they
show up to help you people don't society
does not trust police officers you know
so our number one thing as firefighters
is to continually keep the public and us
having that relationship where they
trust us a hundred percent
or what you know I'm gonna walk in your
house on the worst day of your life
that's when you're going to see me so I
need to make sure that you trust me with
one last thing what is the what's what's
the most outrageous thing you've seen
like that was outrageous yeah like
similar to the handcuff thing with uh
the most outrageous like thing it wasn't
even a fire situated was like a middle
winner and a guy broke into a of stables
that we have in our area and he rolled
around the horse [ __ ] rubbed it all over
himself and then shoved his entire arm
up a horse's ass okay and who made the
call for that like what he saw and so
what they called you and said hey we got
this guy over here he's rolling around
and pretty much too and so what did you
guys think when you got the call I mean
we see all kinds of weird things what do
you guys think okay guys let's go you
know I mean what was the attitude where
you guys were with the attitude more
left in Tori
was it reluctant were you kind of
excited okay let's check the levels a
little bit of both but it's more like
who's gonna man I really hope this guy
comes with no problems you know I mean
because nobody wants to tackle a naked
guy was [ __ ] all over him so luckily and
what do you did you use the hose on him
no you just wrap him up like a burrito
on plastic blankets and throw him on the
rig you know oh right yeah I mean I
think he needs a blast probably hit yeah
take him back to the station blast him
with the hose you know I put it up there
was he what happened was easy to deal
with I yeah you just obviously had some
mental issues so hey you just wrapped
them up put them in the emos are people
kind of being a little distant about the
way they were wrapping them up there all
yeah throw on the blanket on well that's
when you know the that goes back to
pretend the young guys are here yeah
when you're the rookie you take the
worst job obviously that's right when it
comes to scrubbing toilets or dealing
with that kind of stuff as you promote
and you're longer on the job hey get in
there it was a horse okay towards it I
don't think the horse notice too
all right we'll look thanks so much for
for coming over and and doing this I
really appreciate it and yeah thanks so
much
our guest has been Victor thank you -
Donny Devonian for being here as usual
our engineer is Ari Maness our associate
producer is a little bit Messick my name
is Brent Weinbach the name of the
program is pointed questions thank you
for listening
[Music]